Jake: 干嘛嘞
Jake: What's going on?
Tasha:  不知道
Tasha: I don't know.
Jake: 不知道
Jake: No idea.
Alice:能跟我分纯酸奶吗
Alice: Can you share some plain yogurt with me?
Lucia: 可以啊
Lucia: Sure.
Alice:那我们要这个吧
Alice: Then let's get this one.
Lucia: 可以啊这个是他是一整盒
Lucia: Sure, this one is a whole box.
Lucia: 一大盒对嗯
Lucia: A big box, right.
Alice:对但是每人200克对对对
Alice: Yes, but each person gets 200 grams, right.
Lucia: 对对也行
Lucia: Yes, that's fine.
Lucia: 而且如果大家想吃也可以挖出来挖
Lucia: And if anyone wants to eat, they can scoop some out.
Lucia: 挖到碗里
Lucia: Scoop it into a bowl.
Alice:然后我不要糖这里面会有一个蜂蜜
Alice: And then I don't want sugar, there will be some honey in here.
Lucia: 嗯好的可以啊
Lucia: Hmm, okay, that's fine.
Lucia: 我喜欢加蜂蜜的
Lucia: I like adding honey.
Lucia: 我投票投票加入你的这个酸奶team
Lucia: I'm voting to join your yogurt team.
Alice:它这个就两三个人的量
Alice: This is just enough for two or three people.
Katrina:  对因为这个眼睛有那个摄像头功能
Katrina: Yes, because this eye has a camera function.
Alice:因为它比较酸
Alice: Because it's quite sour.
Alice:它是纯酸奶那么
Alice: It's pure yogurt.
Katrina:  哎那就是我买这个是19块9是吧
Katrina: So I bought this for 19.9 yuan, right?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Alice:你能喝纯酸奶吗
Alice: Can you drink pure yogurt?
Katrina:  可以可以
Katrina: Yes, yes.
Katrina:  嗯嗯
Katrina: Hmm, hmm.
Alice:就是你吃过纯酸奶
Alice: So you've had pure yogurt before?
Katrina:  没有
Katrina: No.
Alice:这个一点糖都没了
Alice: This one has no sugar at all.
Katrina:  我都行
Katrina: I'm okay with anything.
Lucia: 会比会比普通这种酸奶要酸一些
Lucia: It's going to be more sour than regular yogurt.
Alice:没事你你可以买你的普通酸奶
Alice: It's okay, you can buy your regular yogurt.
Alice:因为我这个可能就两三个人
Alice: Because this one might be just for two or three people.
Alice:你可以买普通的
Alice: You can buy the regular one.
Jake: 豆汁
Jake: Douzhi.
Katrina:  啊哈哈哈
Katrina: Ah hahaha.
Tasha:  没有我只是看到了
Tasha: No, I just saw it.
Katrina:  你你喝过豆汁没
Katrina: Have you ever had douzhi?
Jake: 我喝过啊
Jake: I've had it.
Lucia: 啊我没喝过啊
Lucia: Ah, I've never had it.
Jake: 哪哪一款
Jake: Which one?
Jake: 哈哈哈多少钱啊
Jake: Hahaha, how much is it?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one.
Tasha:  八块八
Tasha: Eight yuan and eighty cents.
Lucia: 怎么如此热情哈哈
Lucia: Why so enthusiastic, haha.
Lucia: 所以它好喝吗
Lucia: So, is it good?
Lucia: 虽然说我在这上了好几年学
Lucia: Even though I've been studying here for years.
Lucia: 但我真没喝过
Lucia: I've never tried it.
Tasha:  我也没喝过这个
Tasha: I haven't tried it either.
Tasha:  是买一送一吗
Tasha: Is it buy one get one free?
Jake: 行行行真的真的
Jake: Okay, okay, really, really.
Jake: 补补补补
Jake: Fix, fix, fix, fix
Lucia: 哎怎么可能哦
Lucia: How is that possible?
Lucia: 你看他有可能是这里
Lucia: Look, he might be here
Lucia: 因为他这里写了乘2
Lucia: Because it says multiply by 2 here
Lucia: 那应该不是
Lucia: Then it shouldn't be
Lucia: 他就是这个价格
Lucia: That's just the price
Lucia: 不过也还行
Lucia: But it's still okay
Alice:这一共三新币
Alice: This is a total of 3 new coins
Shure:  一共3星币啊
Shure: A total of 3 new coins, huh
Jake: 我知道就是大概一个10新币
Jake: I know, it's about 10 new coins
Alice:一个10新币
Alice: One is 10 new coins
Shure:  就是在在在新加坡的
Shure: It's in Singapore
Alice:真的假的
Alice: Really?
Jake: 对在我在我家门口的那个商场里边
Jake: Yes, in the mall near my house
Lucia: 为什么
Lucia: Why?
Lucia: 你们不是靠海吗
Lucia: Aren't you by the sea?
Lucia: 怎么还这么贵
Lucia: Why is it still so expensive?
Jake: 我不知道啊
Jake: I don't know
Jake: 他就是这个价啊
Jake: That's just the price
Katrina:  新加坡物价这么贵
Katrina: Prices in Singapore are this high
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn
Jake: 一个10新币
Jake: One is 10 new coins
Shure:  快给杨老板补补
Shure: Quick, fix Jake
Shure:  3新币咱可劲吃
Shure: We can eat a lot for 3 new coins
Jake: 这多少个
Jake: How many is this?
Lucia: 所有的三星币吗
Lucia: All the three coins?
Jake: 这几个呀几个呀一二
Jake: How many, how many, one, two
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Shure:  10个左右大概
Shure: About 10 or so
Jake: 10个100新币
Jake: 10 is 100 new coins
Jake: 500块钱你花了3
Jake: You spent 3 out of 500 bucks
Jake: 你花了3新币
Jake: You spent 3 new coins
Shure:  3新币
Shure: 3 new coins
Lucia: 一共三新币
Lucia: Total of 3 new coins
Shure:  一共3新币
Shure: Total of 3 new coins
Jake: 呵呵是我是
Jake: Haha, it's me
Shure:  19块9啊 18块9是吧
Shure: 19.9, right? 18.9, right?
Alice:晚上就要拆开这个
Alice: We'll open this tonight
Shure:  3新币差不多
Shure: About 3 new coins
Jake: 是是是你这大
Jake: Yes, yes, you got it
Lucia: 哎我晚上这样拆开
Lucia: Hey, I'll open it up tonight.
Alice:晚上就要拆开
Alice: You should open it tonight.
Lucia: 可呀我们可以那个啥
Lucia: Yeah, we can do that.
Shure:  打电话勒
Shure: Make a call.
Lucia: 就是晚吃
Lucia: Just eat it late.
Lucia: 晚饭的时候吃它刚好可以解腻
Lucia: Eating it at dinner will help cut the grease.
Alice:回去我就想吃这个
Alice: I want to eat this when I get back.
Lucia: 哇塞那这真的好好好划算啊
Lucia: Wow, that's really a great deal.
Jake: 这个还是能感觉出来的
Jake: You can still feel it.
Katrina:  面包在哪来着
Katrina: Where's the bread?
Jake: 呵呵这一毛六的这个
.
Katrina:  面包番茄酱
Katrina: Bread with ketchup.
Katrina:  姐你们面包也可以加酸奶是不是
Katrina: Sis, can you add yogurt to the bread too?
Alice:番茄酱
Alice: Ketchup.
Alice:吃不惯面包
Alice: I can't get used to bread.
Katrina:  哈哈啊
Katrina: Haha, really?
Katrina:  在这面包是吗
Katrina: Is the bread here?
Alice:你去选你想要的
Alice: You go choose what you want.
Katrina:  我就买那普通的切片面包就行
Katrina: I'll just get the regular sliced bread.
Katrina:  明天早饭是自己弄是吧
Katrina: We're making our own breakfast tomorrow, right?
Lucia: 不好意思
Lucia: Sorry.
Katrina:  买点什么酱呢
Katrina: What kind of sauce should we get?
Katrina:  搞奶酪吗
Katrina: Cheese?
Katrina:  还是搞果酱
Katrina: Or jam?
Shure:  啊蒜还有啊
Shure: Oh, is there still garlic?
Shure:  咱们昨天买的那个蒜还有啊有啊
Shure: We still have the garlic we bought yesterday, right?
Tasha: 呦
Tasha: Oh.
Katrina:  123我们6个人是不是拿两袋啊
Katrina: There are six of us, should we get two bags?
Jake: 好啊
Jake: Sure.
Shure:  没有辣的了
Shure: There's no spicy left.
Katrina:  两袋搞一点什么呢
Katrina: What should we get with the two bags?
Katrina:  番茄酱在哪
Katrina: Where's the ketchup?
Katrina:  你们刚有看见吗
Katrina: Did you guys see it?
Alice:没注意到没看到
Alice: Didn't notice, didn't see it.
Katrina:  你吃面包吗
Katrina: Do you eat bread?
Katrina:  早上那他明天早上就让自己吃哎
Katrina: If not, he can eat it himself tomorrow morning.
Alice:我不吃面包
Alice: I don't eat bread.
Katrina:  怎么办那你吃点水果那种
Katrina: What to do, you can have some fruit then.
Alice:无所谓我早上
Alice: It doesn't matter, in the morning.
Katrina:  不怎么吃东西啊
Katrina: You don't eat much in the morning, huh?
Katrina:  早上面包里加搞点啥呢
Katrina: What should we add to the bread this morning?
Alice:番茄片你吃番茄吗
Alice: How about tomato slices? Do you eat tomatoes?
Lucia: 奶酪
Lucia: Cheese.
Katrina:  奶酪也行啊
Katrina: Cheese works too.
Alice:看英国干巴老头吗
Alice: Have you watched that British dry old man?
Katrina:  看
Katrina: Yes.
Alice:又做他的干巴lunch哈哈
Alice: He's making his dry lunch again, haha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈其实他那种果酱也很好看
Katrina: Haha, but his jam looks really nice.
Katrina:  就是他那个切的面包邦硬你知道吗
Katrina: But his sliced bread is so hard, you know?
Alice:梆硬然后
Alice: So hard, and then?
Katrina:  他们说吃这个吗
Katrina: Do they actually eat that?
Katrina:  英国人
Katrina: The British.
Alice:然后搞点那个干巴黄油
Alice: And then they add that dry butter.
Katrina:  也可以拿
Katrina: That works too.
Katrina:  果酱随便哎
Katrina: Jam is fine too.
Katrina:  有了哎还有奶油哎
Katrina: We have jam, and also cream.
Alice:又做他的干巴lunch
Alice: He's making his dry lunch again.
Lucia: 柠檬塔味
Lucia: Lemon tart flavor.
Alice:我们家是不是也有对对
Alice: Do we have that at home too?
Lucia: 对对咱们房子里还有奶油
Lucia: Yes, we have cream in the house too.
Lucia: 你是更想吃奶酪还是更想吃果酱
Lucia: Do you prefer cheese or jam?
Katrina:  我无所谓
Katrina: I don't mind.
Katrina:  我想吃番茄酱
Katrina: I want ketchup.
Alice:那我们找番茄酱吧
Alice: Then let's find some ketchup.
Lucia: 也行那我可以拿一个这个吗
Lucia: Sure, can I take this too?
Lucia: 有人还有别人想吃吗
Lucia: Is there anyone else who wants some?
Katrina:  拿呗
Katrina: Just take it.
Alice:没关系你拿了就有人吃
Alice: It's fine, if you take it, someone will eat it.
Lucia: 那我拿了
Lucia: Then I'll take it.
Lucia: 夹带私货
Lucia: Sneaking some extra stuff.
Katrina:  我也夹带私货了
Katrina: I'm sneaking some too.
Katrina:  一罐冰淇淋
Katrina: A can of ice cream.
Alice:又做他的干巴lunch
Alice: He's making his dry lunch again.
Shure:  感觉OK
Shure: Seems okay.
Shure:  需要再拿
Shure: Do we need more?
Alice:番茄酱
Alice: Ketchup.
Alice:那个
Alice: That.
Shure:  番茄酱
Shure: Ketchup.
Alice:她去找番茄酱了
Alice: She's going to find ketchup.
Shure:  杨老板累了
Shure: Jake is tired.
Jake: 一般啊
Jake: Generally, yeah.
Alice:干巴lunch
Alice: Ganbatte lunch!
Alice:你这边还有时间吗
Alice: Do you still have time over there?
Jake: 有吧我觉得还有40分钟左右
Jake: Yeah, I think we have about 40 minutes left.
Lucia: 熟冻加拿大雪蟹
Lucia: Frozen Canadian snow crab.
Lucia: 刚才路过过这个地方
Lucia: Just passed by this place.
Alice:只有30多G了40分钟
Alice: Only 30GB left for 40 minutes.
Lucia: 哎帝王蟹腿
Lucia: Oh, king crab legs.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha!
Jake: 肢解了放这了
Jake: Dismembered and placed here.
Lucia: 对上次逛了时候还是鲜活的
Lucia: Yeah, last time we shopped it was still alive.
Lucia: 这次已经变成冷藏的
Lucia: Now it's frozen.
Lucia: AI记着哈哈
Lucia: AI remembers, haha.
Shure:  call back一下是吗
Shure: Call back, right?
Katrina:  油油拿了是吧
Katrina: You got the oil, right?
Shure:  油有家里有油
Shure: Oil? We have oil at home.
Alice:家里有
Alice: We have it at home.
Katrina:  那就OK了
Katrina: Then it's all good.
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina:  够了
Katrina: That's enough.
Shure:  车子都放不下了
Shure: The car can't fit anymore.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Shure:  老板的眼神感觉
Shure: The boss's expression...
Jake: 哈哈哈今天只有一车还行
Jake: Haha, today it's just one car, that's alright.
Alice:only one
Alice: Only one.
Shure:  感觉钱包又被掏空了一次是吧
Shure: Feels like my wallet's been emptied again, huh?
Jake: 哦呵背景太绿了我看不出来
Jake: Oh, the background is too green, I can't see it.
Tasha:  啊没咋
Tasha: Ah, not much.
Tasha:  因为这两个才200
Tasha: Because these two are just 200.
Tasha:  可要40块钱
Tasha: And it costs 40 bucks.
Tasha:  这个300克
Tasha: This is 300 grams.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thank you.
Tasha:  那我还回去
Tasha: Then I'll return.
Jake: 您好谢谢
Jake: Hello, thank you.
Lucia: 会员免费领菜去
Lucia: Members can get free vegetables.
Katrina:  那我们是会员不
Katrina: Are we members?
Katrina:  我们买这么多东西了
Katrina: We bought so many things.
Katrina:  可以送我们一袋金针菇吗呵
Katrina: Can we get a bag of enoki mushrooms, haha?
Shure:  3个蛋吧先咱
Shure: Let's get 3 eggs first.
Shure:  来吧开始吧
Shure: Come on, let's start.
Lucia: 我再去拿个车过来
Lucia: I'll go get another cart.
Lucia: 然后我们扫完的可以放另一个车里
Lucia: Then we can put the scanned items in the other cart.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Lucia: 刷完的可以放这边
Lucia: You can put the cleaned ones here.
Shure:  我们在付钱
Shure: We're paying.
Jake: 那
Jake: Well then.
Tasha:  可以啊
Tasha: Sure, you can.
Jake: 好那请吧
Jake: Alright then, please do.
Jake: 去吧就
Jake: Just go ahead.
Shure:  好吧那又靠你了
Shure: Okay, it's up to you again.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 但是券已经用完了是吧
Jake: But the coupons are all used up, right?
Tasha:  看看能不能买点
Tasha: Let's see if we can buy some.
Jake: 啊不用不用不用不用不用
Jake: Ah, no need, no need, no need.
Jake: 一星币的事情用不着
Jake: It's just a star coin, not necessary.
Jake: 呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 我刚刚点开看了一下
Lucia: I just checked it.
Lucia: 我好像又掉线了
Lucia: I seem to have disconnected again.
Lucia: 就在你说完之后
Lucia: Right after you mentioned it.
Jake: 哦没关系
Jake: Oh, it's fine.
Lucia: 我说我去检查一下
Lucia: I'll go check.
Jake: 你只要是亮着的就没关系
Jake: As long as it's on, it's fine.
Lucia: 哦那就行
Lucia: Oh, that's good.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 就是以防万一吧
Jake: Just in case.
Lucia: 他有时候会莫名其妙的掉线我觉得
Lucia: Sometimes it disconnects for no reason, I think.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Katrina:  到时候我们弄完了就往那边移
Katrina: Once we're done, we'll move it over there.
Lucia: 可以把它先都弄开
Lucia: We can open it first.
Shure:  这先先等一会
Shure: Let's wait a bit.
Shure:  问问工作人员吧
Shure: Let's ask the staff.
Alice:又做她的干吧lunch
Alice: She's having her dry lunch again.
Alice:肉放一块吧
Alice: Put the meat together.
Lucia: 这个等一下再放吧
Lucia: Let's put this later.
Lucia: 容易压扁
Lucia: It might get squished.
Lucia: 重一点的也可以分开放
Lucia: Heavier ones can be separated too.
Lucia: 那个料酒
Lucia: That cooking wine.
Lucia: 要不然放这袋子里
Lucia: Or put it in this bag.
Alice:先别放这个了
Alice: Don't put this in yet.
Alice:不不不这个先放外边吧
Alice: No, no, no, put this outside first.
Lucia: 放在外面
Lucia: Put it outside.
Alice:把肉啥的搁过来吧
Alice: Put the meat and stuff over here.
Alice:或者是冷冻的菜也先不搁
Alice: Or don't put the frozen veggies in yet.
Alice:肉肉成盒的搁这
Alice: Put the meat in the boxes here.
Shure:  我快转晕了
Shure: I'm getting dizzy from spinning.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Alice:旋转跳跃
Alice: Spin and jump.
Alice:还有肉没
Alice: Is there any more meat?
Alice:把那几个肉解开搁这里面吧
Alice: Put those pieces of meat here after unwrapping them.
Lucia: 放不下的话就放这袋子里
Lucia: If it doesn't fit, put it in this bag.
Jake:袋子哪领的呀
Jake: Where did you get the bag?
Lucia: 呃呃那边
Lucia: Uh, over there.
Alice:买的
Alice: Bought it.
Jake: 哦买的呀哦
Jake: Oh, bought it, got it.
Shure:  3个袋 4个袋子一新币差不多
Shure: Three or four bags for about one dollar.
Jake: 这么贵
Jake: That's expensive.
Lucia: 这袋子这么贵哇
Lucia: These bags are so expensive, wow.
Alice:对
Alice: Yes.
Jake: 一新币啊
Jake: One dollar each, huh?
Tasha:  可降解
Tasha: They're biodegradable.
Lucia: 现在国内的袋子也这么贵了
Lucia: Even the bags in China are this expensive now.
Jake: 这一块多钱
Jake: More than a dollar each.
Alice:并且他现在你外送的话必须买袋子
Alice: And now if you order delivery, you have to buy the bags.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake: 这一块多钱一个袋子是吗我去
Jake: More than a dollar for one bag, really?
Shure:  一块5一个
Shure: One dollar fifty each.
Shure:  哎又给你换到6了哈哈哈
Shure: Hey, got you back to six again, haha.
Lucia: 哎不过其实到哈哈哈
Lucia: Hey, but actually, haha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 不过其实到处袋子都收钱
Lucia: But actually, everywhere charges for bags now.
Lucia: 不过我没想到
Lucia: But I didn't expect...
Lucia: 国内现在袋子也这么贵了
Lucia: Even the bags in China are this expensive now.
Lucia: 先放这个吧
Lucia: Let's put this first.
Alice:把那个调料给我吧
Alice: Give me that seasoning.
Lucia: 他不好意思
Lucia: Oh, sorry.
Shure:  这个弄了吧
Shure: Let's get this done.
Shure:  就只有这个没动了是吧
Shure: So this is the only one that hasn't been moved, right?
Alice:好这袋就这样吧再加一个也行
Alice: Okay, let's leave this bag as is, but we can add another one.
Lucia: 放这里面吧
Lucia: Put it in here.
Lucia: 这个感觉也可以放
Lucia: I think this one can go in too.
Shure:  这个
Shure: This one.
Shure:  你好
Shure: Hello.
Shure:  你好你好
Shure: Hello, hello.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake: 啥时候买的哦Max
Jake: When did you buy it, Max?
Shure:  我们找找
Shure: Let's look for it.
Shure:  他码呢
Shure: Where's his size?
Lucia: 啊那这个要不放这袋子里
Lucia: Ah, should we put this in the bag?
Tasha:  我们昨天家今天买起来
Tasha: We bought it yesterday and today.
Lucia: 然后还有这
Lucia: And there's this.
Tasha:  帮我开张卡的钱都可以省下来了
Tasha: We can save all the money for opening a card.
Tasha:  开打之后打8.8折
Tasha: After opening, we get an 8.8% discount.
Jake: 好吧那应该开什么还是什么呀
Jake: Alright, so what should we open?
Lucia: 该第一天就开
Lucia: We should have opened it on the first day.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  OK搞定
Shure: OK, done.
Jake: 卡多少钱
Jake: How much is the card?
Tasha:  只要298 跟嫁入土门是一个价格
Tasha: Only 298, the same price as getting married into the Tumen family.
Lucia: 这个会这个外面会有水蒸气的话
Lucia: This will have steam on the outside.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 要不然跟这个放一块
Lucia: Or should we put this together?
Tasha:  258 好吧
Tasha: 258, fine.
Lucia: 因为面包袋子是纸
Lucia: Because the bread bag is paper.
Tasha:  他还比我便宜点
Tasha: It's a bit cheaper than mine.
Shure:  好来来来
Shure: Alright, come on, come on.
Lucia: 这个放到这边
Lucia: Put this here.
Lucia: 然后这个放在这行吗
Lucia: And then put this here, okay?
Tasha:  付钱了吗已经
Tasha: Have you already paid?
Shure:  大小姐
Shure: Miss.
Shure:  对到付钱了
Shure: Yes, it's paid.
Shure:  到最需要你的时候了
Shure: Now we need you the most.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina:  你你是怎么给他报账的
Katrina: How do you report the account to him?
Katrina:  每天都给他报账吗
Katrina: Do you report it to him every day?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Alice:沉的给男人吧
Alice: The heavy one, give it to the men.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Shure:  这个又得端着了是吗
Shure: Do I have to carry this again?
Jake: 护蛋使者
Jake: Egg protector.
Lucia: 我端着吧
Lucia: I'll carry it.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  护蛋
Shure: Protect the egg.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Lucia: 咱们是不是还有个饮料没放到这里面
Lucia: Don't we have a drink that we haven't put in here?
Katrina: 放我袋子里了
Katrina: I put it in my bag.
Jake: 那个还有是吗
Jake: Is there still some left?
Katrina:  那披萨我也来拿
Katrina: I'll also take the pizza.
Alice:那你喝的你拿着还是给你放着
Alice: Are you going to hold your drink or should I put it away?
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Alice:蛋先
Alice: Eggs first.
Lucia: 这个能能放下吗
Lucia: Can this fit?
Lucia: 放不下我就拿着好了
Lucia: If not, I'll just hold it.
Shure:  蛋还是
Shure: Eggs still...
Lucia: 雨轩那个袋子会不会有点重啊
Lucia: Yuxuan, won't this bag be too heavy?
Lucia: 你先先放这里面推着吧
Lucia: Put it in here and push it first.
Lucia: 要不要放这里啊
Lucia: Should we put it here?
Katrina:  鸡蛋不要放这里啊
Katrina: Don't put the eggs here.
Lucia: 哦哎可以可以
Lucia: Oh, it can fit.
Lucia: 同志们鸡蛋可以和这个放一起对吧
Lucia: Guys, we can put the eggs together with this, right?
Tasha:  先放这吧要不要
Tasha: Should we put it here first?
Alice:就先这样吧
Alice: Let's just do that for now.
Lucia: 也行可以都先放到车里
Lucia: Yeah, we can put everything in the car first.
Lucia: 然后一会提的时候再拿出来
Lucia: Then take it out when we need it.
Katrina:  go go go
Katrina: Go, go, go.
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Be careful.
Shure:  哦没买百事可乐我靠
Shure: Oh, we didn't buy Pepsi, damn it.
Alice:盒马大采购
Alice: Big shopping spree at Hema.
Jake: 为什么要百事可乐
Jake: Why Pepsi?
Shure:  因为腌东西的那个百事会更甜一点
Shure: Because Pepsi is sweeter for marinating things.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  可口反正它就不好喝
Shure: Coke just doesn't taste good.
Jake: 好这能推到哪
Jake: Okay, where can we push this?
Lucia: 他不拦着咱咱就往外推哈哈哈
Lucia: If he doesn't stop us, we'll just keep pushing it out, haha.
Shure:  但也上不去啊主要是
Shure: But we can't go up, that's the main thing.
Jake: 挡着挡着挡着挡着挡着挡着
Jake: Block it, block it, block it, block it, block it.
其他人：哎你好车只能到这了
Other: Hey, your car can only go up to here.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Jake: 失败大失败
Jake: Fail, big fail.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  直接这么拿应该就没问题
Shure: Carrying it like this should be fine.
Tasha:  我靠
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Tasha:  好好
Tasha: Alright, alright.
Shure:  那要要不你护蛋吧
Shure: How about you protect the egg?
Alice:护蛋
Alice: Protect the egg.
Shure:  蛋对
Shure: The egg, right.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Alice:护蛋使者是吗
Alice: Am I the egg protector?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure:  当当当当当当当当当当当当当当当
Shure: Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Lucia: 你这个任务艰巨
Lucia: This is a tough mission.
Lucia: 一定要保护好他哈哈
Lucia: You have to protect it well, haha.
Alice:好
Alice: Alright.
Alice:谁把我的蛋撞碎了我就把谁撞死
Alice: If anyone breaks my egg, I'll break them.
Lucia: 哈哈哈好可怕
Lucia: Hahaha, that's so scary.
Alice:确实我们疯P是这样的
Alice: Yeah, that's how crazy we are.
Lucia: 每天被撞的现代人
Lucia: Modern people get bumped every day.
Alice:精神状态良好
Alice: Mental state is good.
Lucia: 不我的精神状态不良好
Lucia: No, my mental state is not good.
Alice:你吗
Alice: You?
Alice:why你会发疯吗
Alice: Why? Do you go crazy?
Lucia: 因为我
Lucia: Because I...
Lucia: 啊会
Lucia: Ah, yes.
Lucia: 但大部分时候我都只是一只树懒
Lucia: But most of the time, I'm just a sloth.
Alice:哈哈哈呆呆的反应慢慢的那种吗
Alice: Hahaha, like slow reactions and dazed?
Lucia: 嗯我的
Lucia: Yeah, my...
Lucia: 我精神上想成为一只树懒
Lucia: Mentally, I want to be a sloth.
Lucia: 但是很可惜我还是一只人类对
Lucia: But unfortunately, I'm still a human, right.
Alice:你会
Alice: You...
Alice:逼着自己快
Alice: Force yourself to be fast?
Lucia: 对对就是为了融入人类社会
Lucia: Yes, just to fit into human society.
Lucia: 我不得不把自己伪装的像人类一样
Lucia: I have to disguise myself as a human.
Shure: 还要上去才对
Shure: It should go up.
Lucia: 哈哈哈微微露出一个轻蔑的笑容
Lucia: Hahaha, showing a slight contemptuous smile.
Tasha:  哈
Tasha: Ha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 上楼出去
Jake: Go upstairs and go out.
Jake: 出去我们在楼底下好像对
Jake: When we go out, we should be at the bottom of the building, right?
Tasha:  啊是吗
Tasha: Oh, really?
Jake: 还得是用我的新加坡的拖鞋
Jake: I need to use my slippers from Singapore.
Tasha:  那个拖鞋走路就不不痛
Tasha: Those slippers don't hurt when walking.
Jake: 这这底稍微厚一点
Jake: The sole is a bit thicker.
Tasha:  我勒个抖
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Tasha:  才走8,000步
Tasha: Only walked 8,000 steps.
Tasha:  真的假的啊
Tasha: Really?
Alice:打车吧
Alice: Let's take a cab.
Jake: 哎你还亮吗
Jake: Hey, are you still on?
Jake: 我看一下
Jake: Let me see.
Lucia: 哎这是一个扭蛋机吗
Lucia: Hey, is this a gashapon machine?
Alice:亮着呢
Alice: Yes, it's on.
Jake: 亮确实
Jake: It's on, indeed.
Tasha:  这个能扭出啥来吗
Tasha: What can you get out of this?
Lucia: 我也是
Lucia: Me too.
Lucia: 竟然扭不出来
Lucia: Can't get anything out.
Tasha:  这肯定是有硬币要投币的
Tasha: There must be a coin slot, you need to insert coins.
Shure:  们6个人正好打一个商务
Shure: There are six of us, so we can take a business cab.
Jake: 对打个商务好
Jake: Yeah, let's take a business cab.
Jake: 就在这等着吧
Jake: Let's wait here.
Jake: 哎这边我看一下在哪打车哈
Jake: Hey, let me see where we can get a cab.
Shure:  应该这就行
Shure: This should be fine.
Shure:  那能停公交就能那啥
Shure: If buses can stop here, then it should be fine.
Jake: 在这在喜茶那合个影吧要不
Jake: Let's take a photo by HeyTea, shall we?
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Huh?
Jake: 就是或者就在这个地方也很
Jake: Or we can take it right here, it's also very...
Lucia: 都可以
Lucia: Anywhere is fine.
Jake: 也很酷炫
Jake: ...cool here.
Jake: 这个地方
Jake: This place is cool.
Lucia: 要扫一下喜茶吗
Lucia: Should we scan HeyTea?
Jake: 我先打车
Jake: I'll get a cab first.
Shure:  没开吧那个
Shure: Is that open?
Tasha:  应该在门外开了吧
Tasha: Should be open outside the door.
Lucia: 哈哈打哈欠会传染
Lucia: Haha, yawning is contagious.
Shure:  后门左拐
Shure: Turn left at the back door.
Jake: 看一下有更好的地方吗
Jake: Let's see if there's a better place.
Jake: 还是还是这吧行吧
Jake: Or we can just stay here, it's fine.
Jake: 哎啥玩意
Jake: Hey, what's this thing?
Alice:这个洞特别像一个怪笑的
Alice: This hole looks like a creepy smile.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice:一个怪笑的东西
Alice: A creepy smiley thing.
Jake: 这吧行吧
Jake: Okay, this works.
Jake: 这好
Jake: This is good.
Alice:两个大蝴蝶眼
Alice: Two big butterfly eyes.
Lucia: 定先把它放一下好重啊
Lucia: Let's put it down for now, it's so heavy.
Shure:  OK这这可以可以OK就是
Shure: OK, this is fine, it's fine, OK.
Jake: 行好
Jake: Alright, good.
Alice:咋啦
Alice: What's up?
Alice:洗不掉了
Alice: It won't wash off.
Alice:咋个办了不咋办
Alice: What should we do now? What do we do?
Tasha:  累了
Tasha: I'm tired.
Alice:累了
Alice: Tired.
Lucia: 加1
Lucia: Me too.
Alice:加2
Alice: Me three.
Jake: 加什么
Jake: What are you adding?
Alice:10086
Alice: 10086.
Lucia: 哈哈哈 10036
Lucia: Hahaha, 10036.
Alice:世上世上无难事
Alice: In the world, there's no difficult task.
Alice:只要肯乐
Alice: As long as you're willing to be happy.
Alice:只要肯乐欢
Alice: As long as you're willing to be joyful.
Alice:什么意思
Alice: What does that mean?
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia: 世上无难事
Lucia: In the world, there's no difficult task.
Lucia: 只要肯乐观
Lucia: As long as you're willing to be optimistic.
Alice:好乐观我看成乐欢了
Alice: Oh, optimistic, I thought it was joyful.
Lucia: 哦哦
Lucia: Oh, oh.
Alice:啊乐观啊
Alice: Ah, optimistic.
Alice:乐观乐观
Alice: Optimistic, optimistic.
Lucia: 观吧
Lucia: Yeah, optimistic.
Lucia: 你如生活的
Lucia: You live like...
Alice:哇哇蛋你没事吧
Alice: Wow wow, are you okay?
Lucia: 热爱什么鬼鬼
Lucia: What kind of weird passion is this?
Jake: 还有11分钟才到
Jake: Still 11 minutes to go.
Jake: 所以放地上吧
Jake: So, let's put it on the ground.
Shure:  先放一会吧
Shure: Let's leave it for a bit.
Jake: 就放这吧
Jake: Just leave it here.
Shure:  （歌词）我在无言的夜
Shure: (Lyrics) In the silent night...
Shure:  洋葱买的吧
Shure: Bought from Onion, right?
Shure:  洋葱买的
Shure: Bought onions.
Alice:买了紫皮的
Alice: Bought the purple-skinned ones.
Lucia: 买了
Lucia: Got them.
Lucia: 好好吧
Lucia: Alright then.
Lucia: 你对生活的热爱
Lucia: Your love for life.
Lucia: sorry看错了
Lucia: Sorry, I misread.
Jake: 这样可以拍吧
Jake: We can film like this, right?
Jake: 这样可以拍吗
Jake: Can we film like this?
Shure:  什么奇怪的事情
Shure: What a strange thing.
Lucia: 你醒了
Lucia: You're awake.
Jake: 你醒了哈哈哈哈哈妙啊
Jake: You're awake, hahaha, that's great.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahaha.
Alice:啊哈哈哈哈
Alice: Ahahahaha.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Jake: 好就这样吧
Jake: Alright, let's do it.
Shure:  来我们叫醒一下AI
Shure: Let's wake up the AI.
Jake: 就这样挺好
Jake: This is good.
Jake: 来来来叫醒叫醒一下
Jake: Come on, let's wake it up.
Jake: 叫醒服务
Jake: Wake-up service.
Katrina:  到底谁啊
Katrina: Who is it really?
Lucia: 呃他的手机
Lucia: Uh, his phone.
Shure:  咱们一个一个露出来吧
Shure: Let's show them one by one.
Shure:  咱们先拍一张
Shure: Let's take a photo first.
Shure:  然后拍个视频
Shure: Then shoot a video.
Katrina:  1234还差一个人呢
Katrina: 1234, we're still missing one person.
Jake: 好等一下
Jake: Alright, wait a second.
Lucia: 呃薇薇
Lucia: Uh, Tasha.
Lucia: 要合个影
Lucia: Let's take a group photo.
Shure:  喝牛奶喝的
Shure: Drinking milk.
Shure:  有一人没露出来快快快
Shure: Someone's not showing, quick quick quick.
Jake: 快快快
Jake: Hurry hurry hurry.
Jake: 晚了再来一次
Jake: Too late, let's do it again.
Alice:还没带眼镜呢
Alice: I haven't put on my glasses yet.
Shure:  而且你没戴眼镜
Shure: And you haven't put on your glasses.
Alice:来了
Alice: Coming.
Shure:  你醒了
Shure: You're awake.
Jake: 你醒了
Jake: You're awake.
Shure:  那已经是2077年了
Shure: It's already 2077.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 等会我把这个带上忘了
Jake: Wait, I forgot to put this on.
Shure:  Wifi没带上
Shure: Forgot to bring the Wifi.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha!
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈没
Jake: Hahahahaha, no way!
Shure:  哈哈哈接收不着信号了
Shure: Hahaha, can't get a signal now.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 马上收不到信号了
Lucia: We're losing signal soon.
Shure:  是吗让自己看的像个活人一样
Shure: Really? Let's make ourselves look alive.
Alice:怎么按反了呢啊
Alice: Why is it backwards?
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Jake: 没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake: 呃没关系歪对啊
Jake: Uh, it's okay, it's a bit crooked, right?
Alice:有点歪说实话
Alice: It's a bit crooked, to be honest.
Lucia: 哈哈搅动转场
Lucia: Haha, let's stir things up.
Jake: 好再来
Jake: Okay, let's do it again.
Tasha: 怎么这么暗
Tasha: Why is it so dark?
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Shure:  非常帅
Shure: Very cool.
Jake: 这次很好
Jake: This time it's great.
Alice:好
Alice: Good.
Jake: 那视频一个一个出
Jake: Then, one video at a time.
Shure:  啊视频好
Shure: Yeah, videos are good.
Jake: 一个一个进来
Jake: One at a time, come in.
Jake: 然后你醒了
Jake: Then you woke up.
Jake: 你醒了你醒了
Jake: You woke up, you woke up.
Katrina:  要说这句话是吗
Katrina: Should I say this line?
Jake: 呵要吗
Jake: Hmm, should we?
Jake: 可以要
Jake: We could.
Shure:  好快快先撤出来
Shure: Okay, quickly, let's get out first.
Alice:来呀谁呀
Alice: Come on, who's it?
Shure:  从杨老板开始
Shure: Start with Jake.
Jake: 你醒了
Jake: You woke up.
Alice:你醒了
Alice: You woke up.
Jake: 进来就呆着
Jake: Just stay when you come in.
Jake: 重来重来
Jake: Do it again, do it again.
Shure:  哎重来没有默契没有啊
Shure: Oh, do it again, no coordination at all.
Tasha:  什么你醒了
Tasha: What, you woke up?
Alice:你醒了
Alice: You woke up.
Jake: 来来来闪开
Jake: Move, move, move.
Lucia: 那个表情包
Lucia: That expression meme.
Tasha:  哦哦
Tasha: Oh, oh.
Lucia: 你醒了快起来做作业哈哈
Lucia: You're awake, get up and do your homework, haha.
Tasha:  哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake: 你醒了
Jake: You're awake.
Alice:醒了
Alice: Awake.
Lucia: 你醒了
Lucia: You're awake.
Tasha:  醒了
Tasha: Awake.
Katrina:  你醒了
Katrina: You're awake.
Shure:  你醒了
Shure: You're awake.
Shure:  你醒了吗
Shure: Are you awake?
Jake: 2077啊哈哈哈哈哈哈傻屌
Jake: 2077, haha, stupid.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahahahahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈卧槽
Katrina: Hahaha, damn.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha:  哈哈哈我靠哈
Tasha: Hahaha, oh my.
Katrina:  这是噩梦你知道吗这噩
Katrina: This is a nightmare, you know, this is...
Tasha:  哈好
Tasha: Haha, okay.
Lucia: 哈哈瞬间变恐怖片
Lucia: Haha, it instantly turned into a horror movie.
Jake: 我靠很难
Jake: Damn, it's hard.
Alice:你不要过来呀
Alice: Don't come over here.
Lucia: 你不要过来呀你不要过来
Lucia: Don't come over here, don't come over.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈根本醒不了
Jake: Haha, you can't wake up at all.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Shure:  别鬼压床了
Shure: Stop having sleep paralysis.
Shure:  魇到了
Shure: It's a nightmare.
Jake:看一眼车车
Jake: Look at the car.
Jake: 还有8分钟
Jake: 8 minutes left.
Jake: 还能再整点活
Jake: We can still do a bit more.
Lucia: 想看一眼那个视频
Lucia: Want to watch that video.
Jake: 好好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Jake: 好慢啊
Jake: So slow.
Lucia: 新物种生活
Lucia: New species life.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Alice:有鬼
Alice: There's a ghost.
Katrina:  太恐怖了这
Katrina: This is so scary.
Jake: 新物种生活确实
Jake: New species life indeed.
Alice:有脏东西哈哈
Alice: There's something dirty, haha.
Shure:  我靠新物种生活
Shure: Whoa, new species living.
Shure:  上面这字还很应景
Shure: The words up there are quite fitting.
Jake: 可以这个
Jake: This one works.
Jake: 个最后一天的开场视频都有了
Jake: We have the opening video for the last day.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  你醒吧然后就大家就都退出去了
Shure: You wake up and then everyone just leaves.
Shure:  我那个叫什么10秒点出率
Shure: What do you call it, 10-second click rate?
Shure:  对哈哈哈
Shure: Right, hahaha.
Shure:  就卡在我那10秒了
Shure: It just gets stuck at my 10 seconds.
Jake: 丰收歌曲
Jake: Harvest song.
Shure:  好好好
Shure: Alright, alright.
Alice:快递快递
Alice: Delivery, delivery!
Alice:你必须给我快点
Alice: You have to hurry up for me.
Shure:  （歌词）我想开着我的烂摩托转一转
Shure: (Lyrics) I want to ride my broken motorcycle around.
Shure:  （歌词）可惜我的心
Shure: (Lyrics) Sadly, my heart...
Shure:  （歌词）我可惜我把车卖了
Shure: (Lyrics) Sadly, I sold my bike.
Shure:  （歌词）我的心呀我的心
Shure: (Lyrics) My heart, my heart...
Shure:  （歌词）变成了处处处处都给你
Shure: (Lyrics) Turned into every, every, every place for you.
Alice:还有大概半个小时能录
Alice: We have about half an hour to record.
Jake: 没问题
Jake: No problem.
Jake: 就上车就关掉
Jake: Just get in the car and turn it off.
Lucia: 当前网络不稳定
Lucia: The current network is unstable.
Shure:  刷哈哈哈
Shure: Swipe, hahaha.
Shure:  啊你在拍照啊
Shure: Oh, you're taking a picture?
Shure:  你浪费我的表情了
Shure: You're wasting my expression.
Jake: 你从后面绕过来吧
Jake: Come around from the back.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Jake: 我开始我开始录了
Jake: I'm starting, I'm starting to record.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Shure:  到了吗车看眼
Shure: Are we there? Look at the car.
Shure:  车看眼车
Shure: Look at the car, the car.
Jake: 还有5分钟
Jake: 5 more minutes.
Jake: 出去等着吧
Jake: Go wait outside.
Jake: 走吧出去吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go outside.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Shure:  （歌词）起来饥寒交迫的人
Shure: (Lyrics) Rise, starving and cold people.
Lucia: 哎我们走了吗那
Lucia: Hey, are we leaving now?
Jake: 你哈哈
Jake: You, haha.
Jake: 你最帅不用不用不用一一一
Jake: You're the coolest, no need, no need, no no no.
Shure:  杨老板哎
Shure: Jake, hey
Shure:  别客气哎呀呀呀呀
Shure: No need to be so polite, oh my
Lucia: 没事就给我吧
Lucia: It's fine, just give it to me
Jake: 呃呃呃这么客气
Jake: Uh, uh, uh, you're too polite
Shure:  行吧那就给你吧
Shure: Alright, then it's yours
Tasha:  哈好
Tasha: Haha, okay
Jake: 蛋呢蛋在蛋在
Jake: The egg, the egg, where's the egg?
Shure: 蛋护好蛋啊
Shure: Protect the egg!
Jake: 蛋在哪啊
Jake: Where's the egg?
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Got it
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake: 没有最帅的人
Jake: There's no most handsome person
Alice:你没有反复吧哈哈
Alice: You're not repeating yourself, are you? Haha
Lucia: 把我吓得又倒头就睡真的
Lucia: I was so scared that I fell asleep again, really
Jake: 走上道路口
Jake: Walk to the intersection
Jake: 这过得去吧
Jake: Can we get through here?
Tasha:  那当然是翻山越岭
Tasha: Of course, it's over mountains and ridges
Shure:  他到哪了
Shure: Where did he go?
Jake: 啊他
Jake: Ah, he
Jake: 他说可以开进来
Jake: He said he could drive in
Shure:  不这是非机动车道
Shure: No, this is a non-motorized lane
Shure:  他进不来的
Shure: He can't get in
Tasha:  哎你小心摄像头
Tasha: Hey, watch out for the cameras
Tasha:  我是说钻的时候
Tasha: I mean when you're squeezing through
Shure:  你
Shure: You
Jake: 哈哈哈我有可能的吧
Jake: Hahaha, I might be able to do it
Jake: 选一个好道
Jake: Choose a good path
Shure:  我们
Shure: We
Shure:  哦这辆什么
Shure: Oh, this one, what?
Shure:  337是吗
Shure: 337, right?
Jake: 776
Jake: 棕色别克
Jake: Brown Buick
Jake: 776
Jake: 那个像吗
Jake: Does that look like it?
Jake: 那车后轮
Jake: That car's rear wheel
Jake: 就是他
Jake: That's it
Jake: 太对了
Jake: Exactly
Tasha:  都是打领带的
Tasha: They're all wearing ties
Jake: 对
Jake: Right
Katrina:  要放后备箱吗
Katrina: Should we put it in the trunk?
Lucia: 放后备箱吧
Lucia: Yeah, put it in the trunk.
Lucia: 哎不放后备箱吗
Lucia: Hey, aren't we putting it in the trunk?
Shure:  啊尾号7008是吧
Shure: Oh, the last digits are 7008, right?
Jake: 对对可对了
Jake: Yes, yes, exactly.
Shure:  啊 7008
Shure: Oh, 7008.
Lucia: 要不放一下吧
Lucia: Should we just put it in?
Shure:  不是哪有后备箱啊你想想
Shure: No, where’s the trunk? Think about it.
Lucia: 啊没有啊没有
Lucia: Oh, there's no trunk.
其他人：不是你要有箱子啊
Others: No, you need a trunk.
Shure:  没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Jake: 没箱子
Jake: No trunk.
其他人：赶紧上啊
Others: Hurry up and get on.
Lucia: 那行吧
Lucia: Alright then.
Lucia: 那我就那我还坐这边了谢谢
Lucia: I'll just sit here then, thanks.
其他人：滴滴专车为您服务请您系好安全带
Others: Didi car service, please fasten your seat belts.
Shure:  我要做来的老板呗
Shure: I'll be the boss, right?
Jake: 呀再次保安位
Jake: Oh, security position again.
Jake: 关吧
Jake: Close it.
Lucia: 理论上说是不是我理财
Lucia: Technically, am I not the financial manager?
Lucia: 应该是保安
Lucia: I should be the security.
Lucia: 然后我下去刚好给你们一开门
Lucia: Then I'll go down and open the door for you guys.
Jake: 哈
Jake: Ha!
Jake: 大车开始撸
Jake: The big car is starting to move.
Jake: 我录完放冰箱
Jake: Once I finish recording, put it in the fridge.
Jake: 放到冰箱就给我导
Jake: Put it in the fridge and then send it to me.
Lucia: 哎所以现在要暂停吗
Lucia: So, should we pause now?
Jake: 对对对就停掉停掉
Jake: Yes, yes, just stop, stop.
Shure:  要暂停吗
Shure: Should we pause?
Jake: 这一路啥也不是
Jake: This whole way was a waste.